[MUSIC PLAYING]
RUSS WHITE: Welcome
to Cloud OnAir,
Google Cloud's live webinars.
We host webinars every Tuesday.
And I'm Russ.
I'm here to talk to you
about Grab and Go, Google's
Chromebook loaner program.
Standby after the session.
You can ask questions, and
we have Googlers on standby
to answer them for you.
So first up, Google's
Grab and Go program.
It's a self-service
Chromebook loaner program.
Before we get into the
specifics of the program,
I'm going to tell you a
little bit about Chromebooks
and Chrome OS at Google.
So we're actually Chrome
enterprise's first and largest
customer.
We have the largest fleet
of Chromebooks in the world.
We manage a mixed-hardware
ecosystem here at Google.
So Chrome OS is just one
component of the broader
suite of applications we have.
We have Linux, Mac,
Windows, you name it--
whatever our users need to
be happy and productive.
And we're also just
another big enterprise.
We also want to reduce costs.
We want to keep our
users productive.
And we want to make sure
they have the tools they
need to get their jobs done.
The benefits that Chrome
OS brings to our ecosystem
break down into two
high-level categories.
So there's the user
focused benefits.
We found that our users
are very happy being
able to switch between
devices, work anywhere,
and just generally
use a platform that's
made for working on the cloud.
On the business side, we found
that Chrome's baked-in security
features make it
perfect for making
IT administrators a little
bit happier with the security
state.
And also reduce the burden of
management on these devices.
So it's a great investment.
They're super easy to
manage, and users love them.
Now it's important to keep in
mind that Grab and Go is just
a small piece of the broader
Chrome OS ecosystem at Google.
Before we get into the
specifics of the program,
I do want to talk
about the problem
that we were trying to address--
IT downtime.
So IT downtime is actually
a very, very big problem
for enterprises.
IHS Market estimates that North
American companies are spending
around $700 billion a
year on broken devices,
IT downtime, things like that.
Now that might be
maybe a million dollars
for a small- to medium-sized
business or up to $60 million
for a larger enterprise.
That productivity
loss time extends
beyond just the bottom
line of the company.
There's also
employee motivation,
corporate reputation,
and the pressure
that it puts on IT teams.
So really, IT downtime
is a huge problem.
That's why we started
digging into this problem
in the first place.
Google's certainly not immune
from those same problems.
Again, we're just
another big enterprise.
The problems that
we saw generally
broke down into these
four categories.
So the first was the
fatal device error-- so
some software problem that
rendered your device unusable.
Maybe you forgot
your laptop at home.
Maybe you lost it.
Maybe it's just not accessible
for whatever reason.
You might be traveling
to a different location
where you either don't
want to bring your device
or can't bring your device.
And then the all-famous
damaged device--
maybe you've spilled coffee
into the keyboard of your laptop
as you rushed into the
office in the morning.
We've definitely all been there.
So our first crack at
solving this problem
was with a traditional
loaner program,
or what we call a
traditional loaner program.
So the employee
experiences the problem,
they come to the help desk
seeking a loaner device,
they wait in line, and they
see someone from the help desk.
The person from the help desk
prepares a device for them,
checks it out,
explains how to use it.
The employee takes
the device, uses it--
probably with a
lower productivity
than their usual device.
And then they return
it when they're done.
Again, they have
to wait in line.
They have to talk
to the IT admin.
They have to go through
that whole process.
The admin takes the device
back, wipes it, resets it,
does whatever they need to do
to prepare it for the next user.
And the cycle repeats.
Now this was definitely
helping solve the problem.
And we definitely
realized some gains
from having a loaner
program like this.
But it still wasn't
cutting it for us.
Somewhere around 10% of
visits to our help desk
were just for checking
out a loaner device, which
is a huge amount of time that
both Googlers and our IT team
were spending on this.
Every step in the process,
people were losing time.
And it really wasn't a
great experience for anyone.
So we took another crack at it.
That's when we designed
the Grab and Go program.
We designed it with
four core tenets
in mind, first being it
needed to be self-service.
We didn't want to have all
these IT admin interactions.
We wanted to allow Googlers to
do this whenever they needed.
Sign-in process needed
to be super quick.
No waiting in line,
no setup, no nothing.
You just sign it and
you're back to work.
Return process needed
to be just as easy.
And of course, it
needed to be 24/7.
Let's dig into those core
tenets a little bit deeper.
First up, self-service--
the whole idea
was that you can help yourself.
The physical manifestation
of our loaner program
is a shelf, devices,
and signage so that you
understand how it works.
These shelves where devices
were constantly charging
are placed throughout
our offices.
Typically, they're placed in
areas of high-traffic, or maybe
outside of a help desk,
where people kind of already
associate IT problems going.
On those shelves, devices
are always charging.
So they're ready to go as
soon as you pick it up.
There's a sign right above
the shelf that explains
how to use the program.
So basic things like just pick
it up, log in, and get going.
We found that users
had a lot of questions
about how the program worked.
And they were kind of unsure
of the easy nature of it.
So having that sign there really
makes them feel a lot better.
And then of course
on the devices
themselves, we also
brand them so that people
know this is a loaner device.
And we answered some FAQs.
We put stickers inside the
laptop, as well-- for things
like getting set
up or how to return
the device-- both
common questions
that we found with our users.
One kind of invisible,
magic piece of this
is, as soon as a user
logs in to the device,
we push a custom Chrome
companion application
to the device.
And that reports back to us
that that user has signed in,
and it assigns it to them.
And we'll explain that in
a little bit more detail
later in this presentation.
The next piece-- quick sign-in.
So like I said, users need to
be able to sign in and get back
to work quickly.
And IT admins didn't really
need to be involved in that.
So Chrome OS actually provided
a lot of the key ingredients
here.
The things like Chrome Sync
and Google's prolific use
of G Suite applications made
Chrome OS an easy choice,
in this respect.
A user could just
take it, log in
with their corporate
account, and they were back
to work just like that.
Return process needed
to be just as easy.
Sign out, close the lid, put it
back on the shelf, plug it in,
and you're done.
Chrome OS again provided
a key ingredient here.
So we needed to
create a system that
allowed devices to
go from user to user
to user, without IT
admins being involved.
We didn't want to wipe these
devices every single time
someone used them.
So Chrome OS has this
feature built into it
where profiles are
encrypted by default.
So you don't have to worry about
data going from user profile
to user profile.
And lastly, 24/7 access.
Mishaps certainly don't
stick to a schedule.
Neither do we.
This loaner service needed to
be out there, barrier-free,
for people to use it 24/7.
Now in the early days of
designing this program, we
often came back to the
idea of, can we just
put Chromebooks out there
on a charging shelf,
and not add all these
bells and whistles--
no signage, no automation, and
maybe not even Chromebooks?
So that's when we started
to dig into, well,
beyond those four core tenets,
what things are really, really
important to us in
building out this program?
So the first of those things--
the first key ingredient
that we had identified
was, Chromebooks really adds
so much to the equation.
Here's a list of a few things
that we think are important.
The first is, Chromebooks
scale really, really easily.
They're super easy to set up.
It takes about 10
minutes, on average,
to deploy a Chromebook.
And we can add
devices to the fleet
very quickly because of
that and kind of scale
up how many devices
were out there.
In addition, security
was top-of-mind for us.
These devices weren't going to
see IT admins all that often.
So we wanted to make sure
they were super secure.
Things like encrypted profiles,
automatic wipe, verified boot,
and sign-in restrictions
are really important to us.
We'll dig into those
actually a little bit more
on the next slide.
Switching easily between
devices was also very important.
So the best experience would
be, if you use a Chrome
device as your primary
device, and you're
using a Chrome device as
a loner, it was seamless.
At Google, we use the
Chrome browser quite a bit.
So that made it easy for our
people on other platforms.
So if you are using the Chrome
browser on, say, a Windows
machine--
logging into a loaner Chromebook
was a very familiar experience.
On top of that,
Chrome Sync made it
so that things like bookmarks,
and data, and settings also
made it onto that device,
making it a very familiar feel.
Grab and Go Chromebook models--
we found that picking
very durable models
was important to the
program being successful.
So we wanted
enterprise-grade devices
so that our users could be
as productive as possible.
But we found what we called
the rental car effect.
So if you are using
a loaner device,
you didn't really treat
it the same as you would
your own device.
And we wanted to make
sure all of our devices
could stand up to that
wear-and-tear of a loaner
program.
And last but certainly
not least, Chrome OS
is loaner program
ready out of the box.
The features that I
talked about earlier do
need to be configured.
But it just takes a few clicks
in the Chrome management
applications.
So let's talk about
those security
features that are
so important to us.
First, there is system updates
being automatically downloaded
and installed on every device.
This was a great
piece-of-mind feature for us.
And it made it so
that we didn't need
to worry about taking these
devices in, updating them.
It would all happen while they
were out working with users.
Only users on a
specified domain can
log in to our loaner devices.
So only Google.com
users can log in.
And we have guest mode
disabled by default,
but you can enable it.
We'll talk about
that more later.
Policy enforcement-- even
after factory reset--
was also important.
We didn't want devices to walk
off, someone to factory reset
it, and then it's their device.
We wanted it to stay
in the loaner program.
So auto domain re-enrollment
was a key feature
that we relied on.
User data being encrypted
between the different profiles
was also key.
We needed these devices
to go from user to user,
as I mentioned before.
And lastly, Chrome OS has
baked in tamper protection.
It's called verified boot.
And that makes sure that
there's nothing funny
going on with the OS
already on the device.
Design considerations-- so
there are three key ones here.
The first is the signage
that I mentioned before.
All the signage and
stickers that we use
are very intuitive, very
easy to understand just
in a minute of reading it.
The signs, which I'll
show a little bit later,
have just three steps.
All the stickers just
have a few steps,
so that you can quickly
understand what's
going on with the program.
The Chrome companion
app that I mentioned
before also pops up
as soon as you log in,
and gives you kind of some
handholding guidance on how
to use the program, how it
works, and it eases some
of those fears that
users might have-- like,
do I need to check this out, do
I need to talk to an IT admin?
No, it's all taken care of.
And lastly, follow-up details
are emailed to the user.
So in a case that users
have even more questions--
maybe we want to tell them what
their return date is for that
device, or maybe we want
to nag them and say, hey,
you've held onto this
for a little too long--
all of that is
facilitated via email.
Automation-- this is another
key piece of the experience.
Now I've mentioned the Chrome
companion app a few times.
But the whole
brain of the system
is a custom App Engine
application that we built,
that drives the whole program.
Now this makes management of
the program super easy and just
about hands-off.
That backend application
tracks device usage,
it tracks availability
of each charging rack,
and it also notifies
the users if they
need to return the device.
Maybe they need to extend
it, or extend their loan,
or keep it for a
little bit longer.
Let's dig into this
a little bit more.
So the first piece of this
automation that's vitally
important is the Chromebook.
We've already covered that.
The baked-in features
make Chrome OS
an easy and very important
part of the program.
Google's admin APIs allow
us to enable key features
that keep those
devices safe, secure,
and usable by our users.
And then one of the
policies that's pushed
is actually that
Chrome companion app.
You can push
applications via policy.
When that application installs--
as soon as the user logs in--
it then phones home to
the App Engine backend,
where reporting is done,
where emails are sent.
We already talked about
a few of those things.
The other important thing
that backend application does
is integrate with things
like reporting systems
to work seamlessly with
Google's BigQuery and Datastore.
And it allows us to time to
things like ticketing systems
that we use internally.
So does this work?
Yes, definitely.
We've been really happy
with our loaner program
internally at Google.
Around a third of
all Google employees
use a Grab and Go
device each year.
That's roughly 275 loans
per day and growing.
Around half of program uses are
to remedy a true productivity
blocking problem.
Previously, those problems may
have taken up to a day or more
to resolve.
So gone are the days
of waiting weeks
for a replacement
device, or maybe a day
while the IT department
troubleshoots your problem.
Your back up and
running instantly now.
The other half of usage
is more for users that
want some kind of convenience.
So maybe they're
running between meetings
and don't want to carry
a laptop with them.
Or they're traveling
and they don't
want to bring their
laptop with them.
We found that this is
a nice convenience.
It definitely keeps
people productive.
And it's also been a nice
perk for a lot of Googlers.
And lastly, we estimated that
in its first year of operation,
this program paid for itself--
in productivity time
saved-- after only 50 days.
And now that includes
our capital investment,
the time we invested
into it, and everything.
50 days is a great
ROI on this program.
So a few of the use cases
that I mentioned earlier--
so there are actually
three buckets of use cases
we've identified.
The first is that
productivity-blocking use case.
So those are the broken
devices, the lost,
the forgotten devices, the
places where you just wouldn't
have been working otherwise.
On the convenience
side, I mentioned
there is travel, on-the-go
between meetings.
But this third
category we've found
is very interesting, which
is introducing Chromebooks
to your organization.
The Grab and Go program can
be a really interesting way
to break the ice with users that
don't have a lot of experience
with Chrome OS.
It's a fantastic way to
show the power of Chrome OS
and also kind of save
the day at the same time.
So if you're looking to
expand your Chrome OS
footprint at your company,
this might be a fantastic way
to do it, and have an easy
win for the IT department.
So why should you adopt
Chrome Enterprise Grab and Go?
First and foremost,
reducing downtime.
Keeping your
employees productive
is top-of-mind for us.
And it should be for you too.
Grab and Go is also
a technology enabler.
It's an easy win for
an IT department.
And it makes your
users a lot happier.
It removes frustration,
stress, and it's really
a fantastic safety
net at the bottom
of many, many broken journeys.
It's super easy to implement.
Chrome OS has these
fantastic features
that you can enable just
by clicking a few buttons.
And we've made it even
easier, which I'll give you
some clues on that in a minute.
And lastly, it allows
your IT department
to focus on fixing problems,
rather than handing out
loaners.
Like I said earlier, around
10% of visits to our help desk
were just for loaner devices.
And I'm sure that's
true at other companies
offering a similar
loaner program.
So this allows
your team to focus
on the really
tough aspects of IT
and maybe the not-so-enjoyable
parts of inventory management.
How to get started--
we made it super easy.
The first thing you should
do is go to g.co/grabandgo.
We have a white paper with
lots more details on how
our loaner program works.
So you can give that a look.
And you can also
sign up for updates
on how the program
is progressing
and what we're sharing
at any given time.
And you can also access all of
our open source resources that
we've made available on GitHub
at GitHub.com/Google/loaner.
And now on GitHub,
we have everything
from code, to instructions,
to setup materials,
to even the images and assets
that I'm going to show you
in just a minute here.
So give those two things a look.
And let's jump into a
couple of demos here.
So the first thing
I'm going to show you
is a video demo of
the companion app
that I've mentioned a
couple of times here.
This application that you're
about to see is the bare bones,
basic, out-of-the-box
experience.
This application
is incredibly easy
to set up, incredibly
easy to customize.
And I'll go through
where those customization
options are later.
First thing that happens
when you sign in,
you see this
application pops up.
In the bottom left-hand
corner, the icon shows up.
And this reader is the
first thing that you see.
Let's get started.
It explains how
the program works.
It gives you information on what
the program is and kind of sets
you off in the right direction.
The next thing
that we've included
is a survey that
asks you maybe, what
you're using the device for.
That's one of the
things that we used
to do capacity-planning at
Google for our loaner program.
So we think that's important.
But you can change this to
however you want it to be.
Every screen that you see
here is fully customizable.
The next thing is
setting a return date.
Again, it's fully customizable.
You can say, this
is due tomorrow.
Or you can say, let us know when
you're going to bring it back.
And the last thing
here before you go,
this is some return
instructions.
A lot of our users were
having trouble understanding
how to return the device.
It was a little bit too easy.
So we wanted to give some
instructions-- again,
fully-customizable here.
So this is the persistent
app experience.
You can get here by
launching the application
by clicking on the icon.
And you have a
couple of functions
that you can perform here.
One is extending the loan.
So you can click into it,
pick your new return date,
and tell us when you're
bringing it back.
The next thing that you
can do is enable guest mode
on this device.
And as I mentioned, by
default, we disable guest mode.
But we found that
a lot of Googlers
wanted to use these devices
to facilitate things
like interviews, and
have a candidate do
some coding on the Chromebook.
So enabling guest mode was a
nice way to accommodate that.
And then lastly, you can
mark the device as returned.
This helps program
administrators know
this device is on its way back.
It also helps that user to
close the loop on the loan.
It gives them that last
prompt to bring it back--
again, return
instructions, helping them
understand how to
bring this back, what
they should be doing.
In the next view here
that you're going to see,
there's another survey.
This is a general CSAT survey.
You can put whatever
you want here.
We found that CSAT was useful.
And are you sure?
Just confirming, are you going
to bring the device back--
put it back on the shelf--
again, fully customizable.
And that's it.
So the next thing the user is
going to do is close the lid,
bring it back to the shelf,
plug it in, and they're all set.
The next thing I'm going to
show is a welcome animation.
Now this animation is
something that we've
decided that we want to
show in that application.
Instead of that
static text, we found
that animations for key
components of the workflow
can be a little
bit more inviting
and will communicate key
information a little bit more
effectively.
Both of these
animations and the shelf
sign that I am going
to show you are
provided open source on the Grab
and Go application by default.
Welcome, inviting image,
let's get started.
It gives you a quick walkthrough
of the app experience itself,
enabling guest mode,
extending loan duration,
and accessing the FAQ if
you have more questions.
You can go into to
the app at any time.
And when you're ready
to return-- again,
we want to reinforce--
click that button
and bring it back to us.
And this is just looping
again that you see here.
The next animation
that I'm going to show
is for the return flow.
Before you return it, there's
a couple things we need to do.
The first, we found
that a lot of our users
were leaving USB devices
plugged into their device.
So we tell them
to pull those out.
Bring it back to the
shelf, plug-in the device.
Having it fully charged for
the next user is useful.
If you do distribute chargers
with your loaners, return that.
And you're all set.
Now again, these animations
can be shown in the app itself
as a part of the experience.
And we think that's a great
way to really reinforce
these key points.
And the last piece here
is actually the shelf sign
that we recommend using.
You can see this
just linked directly
to our GitHub repository.
And this is a really, really
easy flow to understand.
You grab a device, you log
in, and you get back to work.
It's as simple as that.
All the stickers that we
recommend using for our devices
and understanding the
program a little bit better
are also in the same
repository on our GitHub repo.
So that's about all I've got
in the demo space for you.
That's a wrap.
Stay tuned.
We're going to switch over to a
live QA in just a few minutes.
Thanks for watching so far.
We'll be right back.
Thanks for sticking with us.
I think we're going to
switch over to questions now.
So the first one that
I see that's come in
is, how many devices
should I plan
to buy for my company's
Grab and Go program?
We don't have a specific
number that we recommend.
Generally, there are ratios
that you can stick to.
But every business, every
enterprise, every use case
is going to be a
little bit different.
We found that some
companies don't even
want to use this program
as a loaner program.
It's more just a
shared fleet of devices
for maybe manufacturing
line workers,
or something like that.
So keep the use case in mind.
But for a loaner program,
what we recommend
is somewhere between one
device for every 30 employees
and one device for
every 50 employees.
So the 1 to 50 ratio will
keep your fleet pretty slim.
And it's going to
be highly utilized.
And you might have some outages.
1 to 30, you'll add a
little bit more slack.
And you might see more of
that kind of convenience
usage creeping in.
For us, that's OK.
We actually tend to stray
more toward the 1 to 30
side of things.
But it's constantly
changing at Google.
So in summary, do what's
best for your company.
And I would say start small.
Put a couple of
deployments out there.
See how they are performing.
Adjust the numbers.
Find your min and max
numbers and go from there.
Next up, can I deploy a VDI
solution with Grab and Go?
Yes.
So that's definitely possible.
We think that the
beauty of this program
is that it's kind
of just Chrome OS.
And then we've added some great
management features and user
experiences on top of it.
So it should be adaptable
unless you've got an outlier
setup with your VDI solution.
But all of this should work.
And we've actually heard
of some customers planning
to use this as almost a
thin client replacement
for their employees.
So definitely give it a go.
Can I recreate this
for my small business?
Yes, definitely.
One of the beautiful
things about open
sourcing this is that anyone
can pick it up and run with it.
There is a minimal
amount of effort
that you'd have to put in to
get the out-of-box experience
working.
But this scales from even a
small business all the way up
to a large enterprise
just like Google.
So give it a go.
Do you supply chargers
with Chromebook loans?
So initially we did.
Now we actually don't
for a couple of reasons.
The first and biggest reason is
that those chargers disappeared
really, really quickly in the
early days of the program.
So we were giving out
chargers and devices
kind of on a one-for-one basis.
We got all the devices
back, but we got about 10%
of the chargers back.
And chargers are not cheap,
especially on those numbers.
So initially, we
elected to kind of scale
back how many charges
we were giving out.
Later, the company
aligned on USB-C charging.
And we kind of took our cue
from the broader company
and said, let's align all
of our devices in the loaner
program on USB-C
charging so that people
don't need chargers.
Typically, Googlers will have
a USB-C charger at their desk,
in conference rooms,
wherever they're working.
So they no longer needed
a charger in those cases.
That was a nice, happy
accident in the end.
But I would say if you don't
have that same charging
environment for your entire
company, start conservative.
And make sure that you're not
spending too much on chargers
like we did in the early days.
Do I need to use
GCP for Grab and Go?
Out of the box, yes.
We use GCP, we recommend
GCP, the integrations
are super easy.
But again, the beauty
of it being open source
is that you can adapt this
to just about any use case.
If you don't want to use GCP,
pull out the GCP components
and add in the
ones that you want.
What do you do about users that
don't return their Chromebook?
Can you talk more about how
you communicate with users?
So somewhere in the neighborhood
of 2% or 3% of loans
go into kind of like a lost
or a super long loan state.
For those users, we have a
couple of different approaches
that we're experimenting
with right now.
The first and one that's
baked-in by default
with the Grab and Go
program is nag mail.
So we'll send reminder emails
to bring the device back
on a recurring basis.
And we found that those
are surprisingly effective.
We've also experimented
with locking
devices that have gone missing,
but are still being used.
Or also copying
managers on nag mails.
Both appear to be
just as effective.
If we're not seeing any
activity on the device--
if nobody's logging in,
if nobody's using it--
we consider it lost.
And the Chrome management suite
has these really great features
that allow you to essentially
lock-out a device.
We do that for all
of those devices.
If we're still
seeing activity even
after those, maybe, manager
escalations and nag mails,
we'll reach out directly.
And we're starting programs
now where we're reaching out
and we're finding
that a lot of teams
that are hanging onto Grab
and Go devices for a long time
have a really fantastic use
case for just using Chrome OS.
So what we're doing in
a lot of those cases
is just buying Chromebooks
for those teams
and solving the problems that
they're having and also getting
our loaners back from them.
How technical do I need to
be to deploy Grab and Go?
Quite technical.
But there's a bit of a
spectrum that exists here.
So if you want all the bells
and whistles that come with Grab
and Go-- yes, it is a
technical deployment
and it's going to require
you to know your stuff.
But if you want to start
small-- really, really small--
you don't need all those
bells and whistles.
You can put Chromebooks maybe
at your help desk and say,
hey, you know you're
working with an IT tech,
and it's taking a long time
to get your problem solved,
just grab a Chromebook.
That's a fantastic
way to get started.
At Google, we wanted
the bells and whistles.
We wanted the program
to manage itself.
And we wanted it to
be very hands-off,
so we built this big program
that allowed us to do that.
So how technical do you need
to be for the full bells
and whistles?
We recommend that a systems
administrator is involved.
There is some GCP work.
You need to know
Python, TypeScript.
You need to be comfortable
working with App Engine
applications,
Chrome applications,
and maybe making some
minor adjustments
to the open-source application.
If you want to go even
further and customize it
for your organization,
you might want
to do that too and bring
in some developers.
It's really up to you.
But just know that there
is a minimum requirement
of technical skill here.
Am I able to work with a partner
to implement Grab and Go?
Actually, a great segue here.
So if you do want a
Grab and Go program,
but you don't have
the technical skills--
or maybe you just don't have
the time to customize and set up
this application yourself--
we do recommend that you
go and talk to the partner
that you've worked with and
ask them about Grab and Go.
We're also in the process
of training several close
partners of Google's
and showing them the way
that Google does Grab and Go
so that they can reproduce
that for customers.
So again, if you
fit that mold of,
you don't want to do
all these deployments,
you just want to ask a partner
to do it-- definitely reach
out, have that conversation,
and get things going.
We're expecting to be able
to publish a list of partners
that we've worked with and that
are ready to deploy Grab and Go
in the next few months.
So I think those are all
the questions that I've had.
Thank you very much
for joining us.
You should stay tuned
for the next session.
That's going to be CE TV,
First Steps with Apache Kafka
on Google Cloud Platform.
Thank you again,
and have a good one.
[MUSIC PLAYING]